[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle donc alpha
bank à bali je viens de la guinée est
très souvent me demande quel guinée il
s'agit la seule l'unique la république
de guinée celle que tout le monde a
copié parce que nous avons le copyright
donc la guinée-bissau les quads plat
guinée équatoriale et ses trains ils ont
rajouté un petit truc à la chose que
nous avons créé en 1958
c'est donc la guinée de ahmed sékou
touré c'est la guinée de djibril tamsir
niane
c'est la guinée de black m
c'est la guinée 2ème hdc la guinée des
frères pogba je viens de cette guinée là
alors en venant ici j'étais partagé
entre vous parler de mon l'institution
de microfinance qui a aidé environ 7000
jeunes à s'installer et à développer
leurs activités à travers le crédit ou à
vous parler de mon aventure dans
l'apiculture l'agriculture donc où nous
avons créé notre propre label d'export
de miel ou d'une toute autre aventure
qui a impacté ma vie va impacter la vie
de milliers de jeunes guinéens et qui je
suis sûr si elle est appliquée
correctement dans les pays africains va
impacter la vie de millions de jeunes il
y a quelques années en guinée en
collaboration avec le gouvernement
guinéen
nous avons développé un petit projet
dont je vais vous parlé tout à l'heure
mais avant cela savez-vous que en
afrique du sud du sahara
les statistiques disent qu'il faut trois
étudiants pour avoir accès à un livre
donc un livre c'est quelque chose de
rare
n'est ce pas moi je suis allé dans une
école dans une université publique
africaine avant de partir à l'étranger
et le choc
il est terrible quand vous êtes sevré de
livres pendant que vous étudiez en
afrique et vous partez en europe et vous
avez une abondance de titres auxquels
vous faites face mais il ya également
une rareté des enseignants est une
rareté des salles de classe dans les
universités l'université de ouagadougou
ne compte que vingt mille places pour 70
mille étudiants je suis sûr que c'est la
même photographie dans toutes les
universités africaines
francophones surtout les gens se
bousculent le matin pour avoir les
premières places devant et écouter le
professeur mais aussi certains font tout
leur cursus sans avoir accès à une
ressource pédagogique qui peut
agrémenter leurs recherches
alors avec le gouvernement guinéen nous
avons développé
ceci vous l'attendiez elle est arrivée
sar série la table et didactique
guinéenne pour une tablette acheter
bénéficier d'un accès à plus de 500
cours en ligne
cent mille livres et ressources
pédagogiques ainsi que tous vos supports
de cours st séries pour chaque étudiant
plus qu'une tablette android 5.1 elle
est dotée d'un processeur quad core
médiathèque d'un écran 10,1 pouces de 1
giga de ram ddr3 et 32 gigas de mémoire
et d'une caméra de 5 mégapixels avec
flash série est disponible dans toutes
les agences et points de service
jatropha sa série
chaque étudiant ou une tablette une
tablette une seule 350 mille ouvrages
500 pour embarquer des mook donc des
classes virtuelles
les stocks des bibliothèques virtuelles
des tutoriels tout ça pour 2 $ par mois
ça fait rêver
là je vois que les gens bouillant les à
nos envies
oui mille étudiants guinéens ont eu
accès à ce petit instrument wimille
étudiants qui seraient dans la famille
statistiques de la banque de la banque
mondiale oui mille étudiants qui
seraient en train de se bousculer devant
un amphithéâtre pour avoir accès à une
place à l'avant et écouter leurs
professeurs si oui mille personnes ont
pu sensibiliser vingt mille autres
personnes à l'accès aux contenus à
travers le numérique
en faisant ce projet on a eu beaucoup de
difficultés mais surtout on a rencontré
beaucoup de gens qui nous ont partagé
leurs
qui ont partagé avec nous leurs peurs
les enseignants ont partagé la peur de
se faire remplacer tout simplement par
la tablette
les chercheurs ont eu peur de se faire
piquer les résultats de leurs recherches
à travers la tablette les parents
d'élèves ont eu peur que ces tablettes
nous serve à autre chose que d'avoir
accès à des livres je parle notamment
d'avoir accès aux réseaux sociaux et
surtout de visiter les sites web non
recommandés et bien tenez vous bien
malgré tout ceci nous avons mis en place
ce projet nous avons distribué wimille
tablettes aux étudiants de guinée mais
qu'est ce que nous avons appris et pour
nous quelle est la leçon a répliqué dans
les pays africains
premièrement un outil informatique et
numérique ne peut en aucun cas remplacer
un professeur un professeur aide à
organiser la connaissance dans la tête
de l'étudiant le défi des prochaines
années ce n'est pas d'avoir accès à
toutes ses ressources à toutes ses
ressources
c'est d'avoir une organisation face à
autant de ressources dans les années 80
on nous parlait de la famine du livre la
menace qui vient dans les 30 prochaines
années
c'est l'âme c'est la menace de la biblio
diversité c'est à dire que nous allons
être sujet à un bombardement intense et
intense de titres venant de l'étranger
parce que au niveau de nos universités
les enseignants de rang magistral ne
produisent pas de contenu accessible et
le numérique bien gérer tout ça le
numérique vient régler tous ces
problèmes parce que tout simplement en
produisant les enseignants de rang
magistral règles fondamentalement la
question de la rareté des enseignants
vous pouvez vous asseoir à l'université
d'abomey-calavi suivre un professeur à
harvard
vous pouvez rester à l'université
d'ibadan suivre un autre professeur à
l'université de lagos vous pouvez être à
l'université de conakry suivant
professeurs
à l'école polytechnique mais c'est pas
tout vous pouvez l'écouter encore
l'écouter encore l'écouter parce qu'il
est dans votre tablette
vous pouvez l'arrêter vous pouvez leur
tournée vous pouvez dormir avec lui
pouvaient lui poser des questions
en fait vous pouvez même mettre fin à la
famille statistiques qui voudrait qu'il
n'y ait que 45 étudiants pour un
professeur on aura un professeur pour un
étudiant
mais ce qui est encore plus intéressant
c'est l'accès à l'outil lui-même -
l'outil est cher plus les gens
l'achètent
c'est ce que nous avons réglé à mettant
en place rapidement en guinée une unité
d'assemblage de ses tablettes au mois de
mars prochain
la guinée produira les tablettes qui
seront données à ses étudiants la
troisième chose c'est le contenu lui
même il est temps c'est l'occasion
c'est l'opportunité pour nous africains
le produire de la connaissance de la
fixer de la partager et surtout de
participer à la démarche de construction
scientifique du monde
j'aimerais bien que moi mes enfants
puissent apprendre la tradition
africaine
les us et les coutumes de mon pays mais
aussi d'autres pays à travers leurs
tablettes
saviez vous qu'il était possible pour
les étudiants de médecine d'avoir accès
à l'anatomie et à la physiologie avec la
réalité virtuelle où la réalité
augmentée
plus besoin d'aller dans un laboratoire
ils peuvent avec un tutoriel procéder à
des expérimentations scientifiques dans
leur maison
nos enfants ou nos petits enfants vont
passer leurs examens dans un café ils
passeront les examens sous l'arbre à
palabre parce qu'ils auront leurs outils
numériques accessibles sur lequel ils
peuvent passer révisé passer des examens
se faire évaluer et valider des diplômes
mais en fait nous mêmes le faisons 30%
des diplômes et certificats distribuées
dans le monde le sont pas le numérique
nos enfants vont pourront avoir des
répétiteurs des robots répétiteur ça se
passe maintenant
gt il y a quelques semaines à vienne ou
pour noël les parents d'élèves aux frais
des robots répétiteur développe des
robots l'isère lecteurs à leurs enfants
réfléchissons à comment nous pouvons
participer à la construction
scientifique j'en parlais tout à l'heure
on dit que la fiq a une tradition orale
le numérique nous donne une occasion
unique de fixer notre la moralité de
fixer nos traditions et de les partager
fixer nos traditions fixer notre réalité
va tout simplement sauvé notre culture
mais aussi et surtout partager ce qu'il
ya de positif en afrique est le
téléphone que vous avez la tablette que
vous avez l'ordinateur que vous avez
c'est le début d'une belle aventure
africaine de l' aventure du
développement africain par l'éducation
est chez nous on dit souvent que il faut
une famille pour élever un enfant
mais il faut tout un village pour
l'éduquer soyons le village africain de
l'éducation en participant au numérique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]